So listen, we need to know what's going on
with Donald Trump's health.
In this story I'm talking about physical health,
not mental health.
Mental health of course has also been a big
topic of concern, but that's not the focus
for today.
Last weekend Donald Trump went to Walter Reed
hospital for an unplanned visit.
The white house has since said, Oh, he was
getting a jumpstart on his 2020 physical.
This is not something a president has ever
done.
This is something that dr Sanjay Gupta indicates
is not how physical physicals are done.
As a general rule, it was all very weird.
Walter Reed said they weren't expecting Trump.
Trump was out of sight for two days following
the visit.
Then when he finally got back in front of
the cameras, he looked acutely not good.
So the other day I noticed Donald Trump arriving
on air force one in Austin, Texas.
And I notice a couple of unusual things.
Donald Trump, other than looking very sort
of ginger as he exited gingerly walking I
should say, not ginger as he exited the plane,
left through a lower door on air force one,
not something that presidents tend to do,
uh, but he was also followed closely behind
by white house Dr. Sean Conley, who then got
into Donald Trump's limo with him.
And now it is normal for the white house doctor
to travel with the president.
It is not normal for the white house doctor
to come off the plane right behind the president
and then ride in the president's limo with
them.
A former white house doctor actually said
to CNN that when they were a doctor, they
never rode with the president the entire time
that they were working there.
And indeed when Donald Trump rode back from
the hospital last week, the doctor also rode
with Trump, which is very odd.
We've now heard from Walter Reed staff that
normally when the president goes there, certain
roads are closed, certain corridors in the
hospital are closed.
Didn't happen last weekend because they didn't
know Trump was going.
So dr Sanjay Gupta has been looking at all
of this.
He says, look, you've got a 73 year old Trump
who has heart disease.
He's medicated for it, he's clinically obese.
He admits that he doesn't work out.
He has a long history about lying regarding
his health.
And still now, nine days after this Walter
Reed hospital visit, nothing is adding up.
And on top of it, Trump is now writing with
his doctor in the limo after coming off of
the planes lower stairs, which is unusual.
And again, speculating a speculators might
be thinking that the idea is have Trump come
off of lower stairs in the event he were to
fall.
Uh, he can take smaller stairs.
So for me there is a very simple explanation
here.
They are lying to us.
We don't know exactly why.
We need to know the truth.
They're lying to us.
We're not looking to make fun of anyone for
being obese or being sick or anything like
that.
This is about the lying needs to stop.
It was a lie when Harold Bornstein put together
that bogus letter saying Trump would be the
healthiest president ever to be president.
Trump obviously wouldn't be healthier than
the prior president Barack Obama.
Nevermind every president, irresponsible thing
for Harold Bornstein to say they were lying
when they said Trump.
Trump was I believe six three two 39 which
would put them just one pound short of being
obese.
Trump is closer to six feet tall, five 11
six feet, six feet and a half, something like
that.
Based on being shorter than Obama being shorter
than Tom Brady.
It's lie after lie after lie after lie.
We just need to know the truth.
That's all, and if you really want to see
another indicator that something is wrong
with Trump's health, he has not gone this
long without golfing his entire presidency.
We'll have more information about that.
I don't, I don't want to muddle that in a
butt, but it's a related story and we will
talk about that tomorrow.
Something is wrong here.
We are not being told the truth and I think
we deserve to be told the truth